que faites vous des capsules qui
recouvre les bouchons de champagne
bernard nigaud lui les collectionne il
est ce qu'on appelle placomusophiles et
depuis 20 ans il en a accumulé plus de
10000 dans sa maison de magny les
hameaux
sa plus belle acquisition j'en ai une en
plaqué or qui est un bijou elle est
faite pour rependre faire un pendentif
ou ya des trous pour l'obtenir il a dû
troquer une centaine de capsules qu'il
avait dans ses 5000 double ranger
précieusement dû à la négociation peut
pas fait il faut nourrir oui oui parce
qu'il ya des petits filous défaut pour
encadrer les changes il existe une bible
des collectionneurs elle répertorie les
cotes de 30000 plaques de muselet web
âgé surlignés en jaune ce que je la
voyais j'en ai pas mal mais il me manque
encore beaucoup mais l'important pour
lui c'est de finir les scieries est
alors celle là moi je sais pas pourquoi
j'avais fait une fixation dessus c'est
celle qui sont sortis pour la coupe du
monde de foot en 98 il y en avait trois
une bleue une blanche une rouge la rouge
est sorti à très peu d'exemplaires et
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à trouver et je
lai je suis très content pour assouvir
sa passion bernard parcourt la france à
la rencontre d'autres placomusophiles et
organise même chaque année un salon à
magny les hameaux
mais le retraité assure laisser ses
classeurs pour faire du vtt et aussi
pour s'occuper de ses cinq
petits-enfants all in
oriane aurélien décor